hello I'm dr. pol Abdullah at the former
body minister of Afghanistan and also a
candidate for the presidency not
understand a nation of the education
which is so important not only as far as
salary and poverty but also provide
Institute environment sound environment
for the people to live will peace this
mainly ignored by the donor community or
sort of not taking that serious what's
the reason problem first of all I think
because it's not so visible sort of
contribution and start that much in the
scene so they would like to do things
which are more visible in the scene like
bigger project the any contribution in
helping education it's it's an
investment in the future of our world
and it has to be taken as such in in
such-and-such everybody has to be dealt
with with such a very important and we
should have I'm here which which would
be called the year about education for
all and get all parts of the world
including the activity level in which
millions of people are deprived from the
education primary secondary or anything
at all illiteracy is is widespread in
many parts of the world and try to
tackle the rest of the problems is only
dealing with the symptoms education is
the key for our people will be